[Applause]
we're just out here trying to help
people we both looked at each other that
you know that night and just thought we
could help someone else out so we did
these two officers say they were just
doing their job one night when they got
a call to Mandalay Bay a woman needed
assistance and was trying to escape a
domestic violence situation they had no
place to go so instead of them being out
in the cold with the sick sick little
girl we just you know we talked with
them figured out what's going on and we
just helped them in the best way we
could they did more than just help both
officers paid for the family of Four's
two-night stay at the hotel it's our job
to show up and do what we can to make
sure that they're safe and sound and
that's all we did for that family it
wasn't anything out of the ordinary for
us in recognition of their efforts Tom
Kovac with the LV MPD Foundation gave
these officers the first good ticket
Awards of 2023. this is good ticket
program gives us the opportunity to
highlight those good deeds
and hopefully
shows our appreciation Resorts World
donated a two-night stay at their hotel
along with dining experiences for both
officers and their families both
officers just say they were doing their
job it does motivate me to continue
being you know humble and and
look to do the best thing for people I
was just being myself and wanted to help
out others